foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
we've got an exciting episode today
blade loses its director Ryan Reynolds a
tease what She-Hulk clips and we give
our She-Hulk predictions before episode
seven wow we got a lot to talk about
today with me to do that talking live
from the new rockers actual break room
here
only only doing disingenuous coughs
we've got Brandon Barrack hey we've got
Jessica Clemens
[Laughter]
thank you
I'm just gonna burp
and I'm Zach cuddleston
what's been in the chat already folks
throwing a Super Chat we appreciate you
for today if we hit 250 bucks in super
chats we're gonna do a bonus 15 minutes
at the end of the show we've got a full
show planned we'll do even more show
where we answer all of your blade and
Deadpool 3 questions but that will only
happen if you hit if we hit 250 bucks
otherwise everybody can go to bed early
but first I think we should get into the
headline
okay so yesterday's episode was uh
devoted to the Deadpool 3 announcement
yes featuring Wolverine we got another
video today from Ryan Reynolds on social
media uh another Deadpool 3 video
um I think John do we have this video
here to play hi hi
how are you you have questions yes I I
had a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them right now
like for example how is Wolverine alive
yeah after Logan Logan uh takes place in
2029 totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that
what actually happens in our film is
these
[Music]
foreign
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin
feige thank you MCU
are you Japanese Australian yeah you
didn't know that no no wait for my eyes
yes all right so uh of course that was
that was mostly a bit right
um we removed the original song in that
video covering up most of their dialogue
was a jitterbug by Wham uh for
um uh copyright strike purposes we
removed that and replaced it with some
generic music uh good good work there uh
producer John but um so not any
necessarily new Deadpool news to the
naked eye oh oh what about to the club
did you discern something yeah yes my
source is over at Beck Tech you know I
employ a staff of 2 000 people to
research my points that's how I get all
these hot takes and cool snakes on this
show I got six snake guys uh you gotta
justify you're wearing a tiara oh I won
it yesterday and I was crowned princess
of the break room wait what uh it's a
lifetime of course buckets
okay yeah unfortunately I am now uh with
the death of the queen and everything
else going on I am forced to take on my
duties as Princess of the break room and
I have to take them very seriously now I
think of course
you watch that video and you go haha oh
Ryan Reynolds what a goof and oh Hugh
Jackman he's kind of silly too
look closer at the gestures everything
means something put all the hand signals
together and what you'll get is Deadpool
3 is a musical comedy that will be
partially animated by the folks at Pixar
about feelings that go on inside your
head that's right inside out too in
Deadpool 3 are the same movie oh three
becomes two becomes one three minus two
is one all of the numbers are there
the president is a lizard
what is this Universal episode three get
out of here well some actual news about
this uh do uh because of another uh
actually it's one of the images that
shows in that clip or or no I'm sorry
this was uh separately released on
social media an image of um Ryan
Reynolds Hugh Jackman and Sean Levy
there it is right like uh it appears to
be taken at the same time the film was
was shot and so we're thinking both this
video and the video that came out
yesterday were shot by Sean Levy uh
who's said to be the director of
Deadpool three he also directed
um free guy and some other films it'd be
cool if they were actually filming part
of Deadpool 3 in that house and then
they were like this is the first day of
shooting but we haven't told anybody and
let's get some scenes of Hugh and Ryan
kissing
you know I like what go team gas said in
the chat maybe they'll put out a video
every day yes until September 6th 2020.
that's the movie so they released them
that was the movie what a commitment I
don't know that it will play uh well if
the videos we see are in order you never
know um but uh we're excited and
actually Eric Voss is gonna have full
breakdown of all the Deadpool 3 news on
the new rockstars Channel coming up very
soon I think it's coming out on the
channel tomorrow Thursday so keep an eye
out for that he's going to go into
detail about everything we know about
the movie and comic book implications
and all that kind of stuff oh and we're
going to keep speculating and have a lot
of fun as long as Mr Reynolds will keep
that drip drip of content coming we will
keep suckling
came through drip drip drip drip drip
um in in other Marvel news werewolves by
night is uh the review embargo has been
lifted and so far it has a perfect score
on Rotten Tomatoes 100 fresh on Rotten
Tomatoes not bad not bad at all it's
only seven reviews okay there's the
there I was waiting for the how you know
the the the implications but Tommy
you've probably had seven-ish
girlfriends in your life and how many of
them would give you a positive review I
would say close to zero I would say I'm
currently scoring a 11 okay Rotten
Tomatoes Jesus you can't trust Rotten
Tomatoes though you gotta let the fans
review too and I've got a lot of fans if
you know what I mean didn't Marvel
recently have something uh what's the
name of Miss Marvel had like really
positive uh Rotten Tomato reviews yeah
yeah for most of it's and some of this
is that like um a lot of the major
Publications your varieties your New
York Times or whatever their reviews
don't don't come out until later right
so these are maybe more like Niche
Industries or industry people or yeah
there's a weird one called like the
werewolf press the howler uh Moonstruck
news what do Moonstruck news have to say
about the movie okay
wow and werewolf that's a good review
yeah that is that's an A-Plus
actually what's funny is Wired Magazine
has waited out oh yeah yeah it's pretty
crazy this is one of the longest reviews
they've ever had they went wow oh
it's just a good sign for this and again
everything we've heard about this our
own uh Eric Voss everything he's been
picking up uh from the Grapevine there
isn't this this special presentation is
going to be awesome yeah very special
and we're gonna come back and talk about
this more in the context of Blade uh and
all the blade news that's been coming
out uh in a few minutes
um but we also have there's a new Shield
clip ahead of episode seven coming out
tonight
um it's got It's it was in the one of
the original trailers from the series
it's got man bull Blonsky Jen El Aguila
um and those other characters kind of in
that that therapy looking setting I
think do we have this uh asset to show
as well
um well I've already wasted half a
Sunday on this Expedition so I'm gonna
get moving
oh my God
[Applause]
uh
wait
[Music]
what the hell is going on it's just
two men working through the resentments
in a safe environment James sorry that's
my fault you know what apologize to my
Prius Prime with money I would
absolutely apologize to your Prius if
that'll make you feel better
brother vlotsky's actually taught me a
lot about taking responsibility for my
anger man bull it was a weird lab
experiment don't ask and I am
El Aguila
and before you make assumptions no I am
not a matador that would make the two of
us fighting pretty cliche no he's
working through some identity issues I
am not the one with the issues all right
I know exactly who I am
I am
a swash burglar you keep saying that
like it's an actual occupation
I am a swashbuck I love the way he says
that and also apologies to El Aguila I
think is how he pronounced it I think I
put a GUI I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
give it a shot I don't know however I'm
saying it is wrong but I like the I like
the the She-Hulk deflating noise it's
like it needs somebody to go back and
edit in like uh like balloons losing air
noises every time that was a fart
oh that was also important uh but yeah
it looks like it's wearing for a really
silly episode with a lot of as of now
new characters that we haven't yet seen
in the series uh well checking back in
with Blonsky too which we knew we would
eventually uh but it's still kind of
like up in the air for the major major
overall villain is and all of this I
mean we mostly think it's Todd but uh is
is a meal gonna break bad at any point
in this movie I don't know interesting
you think you might be in cahoots with
somebody who could be the big bad could
be but he does seem like he wants out
the game yeah he just wants to chill
with us yeah he seems sincere uh his
seven soul mates yeah absolutely
um and so in a moment here we're going
to talk about all this big blade news
not not big blade but you know there's a
lot of big news about blade coming out
in the last day uh real quick we want to
shout out our friends at Disney's Emoji
Blitz I gotta tell you this is
absolutely true I've been playing this
game non-stop while I watch TV or do
other things it is a blast Emoji
Disney's Emoji blue it's it's a fun
match three game that like it's a 60
second round so you can jump in while
you're in the bathroom while you're
riding the bus 15 seconds in the back
what the hell are you doing he's a
healthy man what I like most about all
these like zooms do they have an hour
and a half rounds but I like about the
zoom in Jesus Christ they're still going
on in society and at our job all the
time is you can just play a game like a
little bit below this camera and keep
playing the game and you look like
you've been doing that I don't know
every morning at 10 o'clock I'm playing
never know no those are meetings that I
arranged don't be doing that uh but yeah
if you want to be um you know
distracting yourself during a boring
Zoom you could do it then and this is a
little match style three a match three
tank game it's super simple really fun
very addictive it's got Disney Pixar and
Star Wars characters you could be doing
you know Pluto aerial uh Mickey all
those kind of uh fun characters John who
do you like to play with I'm always
trying to match cogsworth with Miss
minutes and Lumiere no but unfortunately
when you do that they just smash this
minute so hard she breaks in half oh
okay let her gears fly everywhere
I had a donkey an ogre wait wrong
franchise okay so download Disney Emoji
Blitz using our link you get yourself a
fun free game you also help support the
the channel here with break room and new
rockstars in general go to
jamcity.me slash Emoji rockstars that's
jamcity.me slash Emoji rockstars thank
you to them get those Star Wars emojis
in there don't forget about them guys
they're important too take me to Jam
City you guys
[Laughter]
uh River
did you guys uh so blue
Bliss loss you see me in the Jam City
yard
director uh Blossom Turk Blossom Terror
because it seems what they said in
interviews they said due to continued
shifts in our production schedule
Blossom is no longer moving forward as
director of Blade but will remain an
executive producer of the film The Flume
of the film Flume flame of the Flim Flam
flop
um of the film uh and then Marvel said
in a statement to thr that is The
Hollywood Reporter The Hollywood
Reporter we appreciate his talent and
all that work that he's done getting
blade to where it is which is a nice
little settlement subtle sentiment oh my
God you guys I'm I'm coming oh there'll
be settlements but yeah and also
production was slated to begin in August
but it was pushed in November and
through the casting breakdown indicates
it may be further to November 2023 uh
release window but you guys I don't
think this is completely negative news
well and real quick so this movie was
slated to come out next November right
November 2023 is when this movie was
going to be filmed finished and released
that's what they announced at Comic-Con
this year and they showed the big face
five graphic they're like Boom Blade
it's coming here go so for a big budget
film this is a little late in the game
to be changing directors especially
they've inspired or moved away from the
last director they have not yet
announced a new director well I don't
have news to make this better but the
former senior film reporter at collider
Jeff Snyder says I'm told that the
current blade script is roughly 90 pages
and features exactly two lackluster
action sequences
um hershela said to be very frustrated
with the process and feige said to be
spread too thin but hey that's just what
sources are telling me don't shoot the
messenger uh so it's like 90 Pages
that's not a lot of pages you know
typically movies are a page per minute
um and maybe if there's you know still
not finished you know they're still in
like the treatment phase yeah in between
treatment and full I also wonder if
they're just not they haven't honed in
quite on what the
story and tone of this movie is going to
be and that's what we want to talk about
yeah yeah because you know the original
Three Blade movies where their own
Standalone thing they were kind of just
like horror action films with with
Wesley snipes's blade this has to fit
into the MCU so even if you want to kind
of keep it that he's this like you know
by night going around and killing
vampire I don't think they can really do
that you know I think they kind of we've
theorized that it might be a Monster
hunting type movie and I wonder if maybe
they just haven't hashed out exactly
what he does in between hunting out down
these monsters right right and um so
another piece of news that's come out
right is that Beau de Mayo who was in
The Writer's room for Moon Knight and is
the head writer of X-Men 97 he's
supposed to be working some on the
script so I mean Moon Knight especially
right like where like Moon Knight is so
associated with werewolf by night and
kind of other like you know a midnight
Sons characters and demons and monsters
and things like that like could could we
be heading towards some kind of a
crossover there well I'll say this
unlike feige it does appear that demaio
isn't spread too thin
bro
I think you guys were are right that
because everything is so connected when
these changes little changes here have
big Ripple effects and changes move
these further on like we were talking
earlier about how why division's
popularity kind of changed the story in
Multiverse of Madness and they did many
weeks of research a lot of research for
that movie they always do is shoots they
did a lot more they added in more
Scarlet witch in that movie uh and it
probably really changed the story so any
small changes they make to any other
property could have bigger ramifications
and all we know about blade in the MCU
right now is that he showed up to Dan
Whitman who had the enemy blade and he
was like are you ready for that or don't
touch that or yeah hey get in my car or
whatever yeah so it does seem like yeah
get out of my dream it seems like they
were gonna whatever blades first thing
was gonna be was maybe a team up yeah
yeah it could still be yeah very much
yeah well and we've talked about a
couple things that have happened
recently and and also real quick there's
a long history of Marvel changing
directors right like the first Ant-Man
movie was said to be
um
uh uh what's his name and you're right
sorry yeah I kept wanting to say Simon
Pegg who makes all the movies with Edgar
right but it's not Edgar right and
you're right they boom there was a real
quick switch they dropped in Peyton Reed
uh not too far stayed on schedule and
that got released into beloved franchise
within the MCU obviously more recently
Scott Derrickson was set to be the
director in director of the first Doctor
Strange movie he was said to do a
Multiverse Madness got pulled out same
Remy dropped in kind of last minute
right right that John Watts left
Fantastic Four that's right that's right
and then he was like I don't know Matt
shackman was set to direct a Star Trek
and there's a lot of shuffling of
directors and it could be it could be a
situation where you know Boston Terri
have like an idea for this movie and
they liked it he was working with the
writer they're building it out and then
they come to him and they're like okay
because they they picked a writer for
this in February of 2021 right so
they've been writing on it working on a
story for a long time I don't know when
the director came on board but you if
you have this story you want to tell and
they come in and they're like okay we
love your story but also we've changed
things about seven other movies so now
we need you to include this in your
movie and you're like I don't really
want to make that movie anymore and then
like that's fair your part ways amicably
and again this is better than them being
two months into shooting three months
into shooting and being like this isn't
working right yeah we're gonna have to
switch I also think like we we kind of
talked about this a little bit but like
Marvel's not afraid to adapt to what
what what moviegoers and viewers are
responding to right and the it seems
like werewolf by night they have a hit
on their hands yeah right so maybe
perhaps with the success of werewolf by
night they're actually like well we've
got to integrate some more of these
themes and this tone to the blade movie
to continue like the spooky side of
Marvel yeah I mean perhaps I'm wearing
this Tiara
I'm so mad about it give it to me it
only makes you it only makes your points
more sales I've been watching it this
entire time waiting well we were talking
about of like because Marvel it's in its
rightful place there hasn't been like a
definitive kind of Marvel horror
property there were certainly some scary
parts of Multiverse Madness whatever but
you know if werewolf by night is kind of
going to be the first test of that as a
tone for a Marvel property and it's
super successful maybe they're all like
oh yeah more of this please right please
make blade be this way and I can't
remember was it Brandon or Tommy was
talking about this earlier in the office
what if this is less blade hunting
vampires and more blade hunting monsters
as a vampire right it's a little easier
to fit into the MCU because to just be
like oh yeah during uh Iron Man 2 uh
there were also vampires all over the
world we never mentioned it no Avengers
have ever fought them or encountered
them but they've been there the whole
time rather if there's not a ton of
vampires in the world there is blade
who's half vampire and he's gonna go
hunt things like man thing werewolf by
night whatever and is this part of the
Multiverse Saga and that like now that
he who remains is dead there have never
been vampires in our universe but now
they can get in because you know the TVA
has dealt with them at some point yes uh
but for whatever reason they haven't
been a problem on our and we're in our
world we know the TV has dealt with them
because there was an episode of low-key
yeah because he mentions yeah uh Mobius
mentions like we've done with vampires
that was a great Owen Wilson impression
yeah uh
you know it's George Bush no matter what
I'm doing yeah it does come on you got
you got your bank Empires they're bad
they want to suck your blood that's bad
uh uh rest in peace
um wait George W well he's dead to me
yeah his dad is dead I'm asking points
of life
uh but yeah all in all like we we wanted
to talk about this because it was a big
story today uh but it's not I don't see
it as like a bad thing yeah you know get
your house
uh luck and whatever other projects he's
doing that aren't uh blade and we
especially wish blade luck because we we
all are rooting yeah they want to make a
good movie they're trying to make a good
movie and as I say at Jersey Mike's
three times a week the sandwich thing
I still think like blade is gonna have
something to do with Kang so like that
might be where this problems are
brushing up to they don't know how to
integrate king or they're having
problems integrated because this movie
was set to release not too far ahead of
Fantastic Four right or no no I'm sorry
I'm a year off you think yeah yeah yeah
it was it was towards the end it was the
end of 2023 yeah so but like deep into
this kind of King Dynasty Arc right well
in films right this casting notice that
we had heard about they were looking for
extras uh from a that could pull off the
look of like a different time period
like when men who didn't have like
braids or extensions or colored hair or
like men who didn't have like closely
shaved hair because
of the time yeah
70s 80s sometime like that yeah you
could have been in it you could still be
in it because they have a chato scene
chat uh but but the fact that they were
doing that made us think like oh is this
movie going to be set in modern day
because the casting notice said this
film takes place in the past but they
might just tell extras the whole movie
takes place in the past they don't have
to tell them everything uh I don't they
were only needed these extras for like a
week so I don't think the whole movie
takes place in the past yeah but I think
it is dealing with time and if if
they're gonna have Kang and blade
interact in any sort of way time is
gonna be part of that there is a weird
comic where like uh Dane Whitman would
they have any blade goes up against Kang
and is able to fight him because he's
not an Avenger it's it's a very strange
story but there's a small history of
that and the fact that all we know of
played in the MCU is that he's talking
to Dan Whitman if he needs that embody
blade for some reason if like the blade
and the ten rings and the Bengal they
all come together uh and these artifacts
are how they're able to beat Kang like
that might be how this all ties together
in in the end and in the end this movie
gets pushed back there's no way it comes
out all the days now we might be lit
okay not not mid at all uh we've been
speculating what are the odds right
we're we keep like maybe trying to push
this by night is is changing their ideas
going forward what are the odds that
were by Knight director Michael giacino
maybe gets announced director what are
the odds how much money you put on a
Jessica
they're giving him a lot of fluff pieces
he's getting a high praise and again the
last time a Marvel director you know uh
left they grabbed a big name in Sam Remy
yeah who's a big name that would do a
blade movie Spielberg I mean Guillermo
del Toro has made it Toro maid blade too
he's out there I don't know that he
needs to make another blade movie yeah
and I don't think they would put it put
him back on Hellboy I want another
however six words
Peter Jackson is not really available
okay thank you for those things I know a
director who's looking for a new project
what's her name could be their third big
movie Olivia Wilde oh
let's see it let's worry darling yeah
don't worry vampire played by Olivia
Wilde come on show me what you got wild
on tomato uh well we'll stop the softy
Brothers make it a boy movie
The softy Brothers the softer
that's Tommy and I's nickname the softy
Brothers but we don't do wrestling there
goes the softy boys we're not wrestlers
who made uh uncut gems I mean that would
be no they mean yeah that would be a
very um handheld frenetic single shot
that would be an intense vampire I mean
there's also there's a lot of great
horror directors out there you know the
guy who just did barbarians
uh kreger uh the guy who did Pearl and X
um John Ty West he's done a bunch of
great uh how's the devil John 8 24. name
him up what about Taylor shotgun
Yellowstone franchises maybe it's time
for him to break into you I want to see
blade go up against the duttons yeah
it's 1964. I'd watch it we can speculate
on directors all day but I think it's
time for you to direct your attention to
camera three we want to thank our
sponsor today athletic greens yeah I'm a
big fan of their product ag1 Oh I love
I'm not good with healthy routines we
know that whoever wrote this copy can go
after themselves but ag-1 makes it so
easy to get all my daily nutrition doing
easy and tasty drink with one delicious
scoop of ag1 you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins vitamins 74 more than I
normally absorb minerals Whole Foods
Source superfoods probiotics God knows I
need them I'm playing Disney Jewel Blitz
too much and adaptogens to help you
start your day right don't drag one
sponsor into them read it's a it's a
mash-up there's an incursion a
sponsorship exactly boys that's your
softy voice that's our brand we're bad
as we want to be this special blend of
ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
your energy recovery focus and even
aging which doesn't happen to me
everybody comes up to me and rubs my
face and goes how you do it baby boy and
I say I don't know I guess my mama do
people do people have a question if
you're part vampire all the time because
I suck ag-1 does so much for you
including supporting better sleep
quality and Recovery plus it supports
mental clarity thank God and alertness
you better believe I'm hanging on by a
thread without my ag1 ag1 is a small
micro habit with big benefits it's one
thing you can do every single day to
take care of yourself and for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping kids get nutritious food
including no kid hungry here in the good
old U.S reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it baby you're
done to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D in five
travel packs with your first purchase
that sounds like a good deal to me all
you got to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athleticreens.com break room use our
code baby it helps us it helps them it
helps you take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional Insurance ag-1 yes thank you
that's lots lots of good uh answers in
the chat about like ideas for directors
for blade Jordan peels
no
Scott Derek I would always take Scott
Derrickson yeah I just did the or he was
a producer on the black phone no he
wrote black phone oh D wrote it and
produced it did not direct it but he was
a part of it and of course he's done the
Sinister films uh I've got a lot of
people were saying let Wesley Snipes
debut directorial debut I might be so
mean he'd be so mean that directed
anything before I don't I don't know
I think Wesley is uh has won some awards
for his director Redbox
he's pumping out some Redbox Classics
for a while uh Theodore's Harris still
in a Super Chat saying who would you
guys want to direct this movie I like
the Jordan peel I do I think that's it I
think I think as much as that'd be an
awesome blade movie I don't think Jordan
peel doesn't need Marvel man that guy's
getting a lot of money to make his own
well and I do let someone who's making
Original Stories for them yeah
I think they would put him in a box
they'd be like oh you can't go that far
well then I don't want to do it at home
producer John brought up so Hershel Ali
has this great relation ship with Barry
Jenkins who directed him in Moonlight
which got Marshall an Oscar yes Barry
Jenkins is doing the um live-action Lion
King sequel that's coming out
um if you guys bring up Joe Mufasa he's
the working title of the film uh so I
mean Dickens would be interesting right
he hasn't done horror or action per se
but he's like a super talented great
director that has a good relationship
with the Stars
did Moonlight and Beale Street could
talk yeah that's why I was like I don't
know if I want blade to get that intense
um why don't we just let Terence Malik
direct it and then we could change the
title of the doll
no we change the title to Blades of
grass that's the easy job
hey that's why we're the song like that
joke I set him up you knock him down
also thank you to our super chatter
Gabriel Martinez thanks for keeping me
entertained during my Amazon deliveries
are you driving a truck right now damn
delivering those Amazon packages oh wait
does that mean he's waiting for his name
I don't know either way he's speeding
listening
uh thank you for your service we
appreciate it well and here's a good one
to transition we're going to start
talking about Deadpool here in a second
okay Cory getting Drilling in the chat
saying yesterday you guys were talking
about Deadpool's suit in the Instagram
teaser video and that's the suit from
the second movie when he's blown up all
right yes I did see after I reviewed the
footage yesterday after the show I said
everyone when I was talking about that I
didn't know what the suit was and it's
clear it is that we thought it was an
all new suit yeah he's not the
traditional Darkness we were scrambling
over here we got excited thank you thank
you Corey but thank you yeah let's talk
more about the dead three Deadpool three
plot uh we had that video they make the
little jokey jokes uh a lot of people in
the chat point out John Boy if you don't
know the channel John Boy they do a
great uh Sports breakdowns and he's
really good at lip reading he did his
own lip reading analysis I think he's
pretty close to what they were saying uh
basically just a lot of slashing and Pew
pews uh but Ryan Reynolds had tweeted
and this was like a while ago over a
year ago I think it was January 2021
yeah he said uh well before Disney
bought Fox Deadpool 3 was going to be a
road trip between Deadpool and Logan
rashmon style for real he says for real
maybe that means not foreign
okay so this is what way this is also
extremely strange because this tweet
actually doesn't make a ton of sense
rashaman is not a road trip with that
road trip restaurant is a an old Akira
Kurosawa film uh that is famous it's
been parried a lot there's a great
Simpsons episode that does this but it
kind of invented the style of there's an
assault and the movie is told completely
from the different perspectives of the
people involved if you saw the recent
Ridley Scott
um Ben Affleck Matt Damon movie The Last
duel where it's like they tell the
entire story from Jody Comer's
perspective the entire story from Adam
driver's perspective the entire story
from Matt Damon's perspective it's that
so like this is rasherman's style would
mean maybe like the entire movie happens
from Deadpool's point of view and then
the entire movie
it's a road trip movie and then you're
hearing the story but like Logan is vain
like that's not how it went like so it's
both road trip and Russia my interesting
yeah yeah so like the framing devices
like them on a car yeah and then it's
mostly through flashbacks or something
yeah but yeah that's very interesting uh
and then this idea has kind of been
coming up of uh there was a comic run
called like we're basically Deadpool
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe uh
it's it's very interesting like
basically they throw Deadpool and
ravencroft to try on my Kyurem and his
doctor turns out to be Psycho Man uh who
uh basically gets rid of all the parts
of Deadpool that are keeping the
psychotic Parts down and he he winds up
killing psycho man and then goes crazy
like killing characters all over the
place he kills a Fantastic Four and it's
insane so could that be what we're
building up to I mean friend of the show
koi jandro is putting the idea that
Marvel or of like Deadpool killing off
the entire like Fox X-Men Universe via
Deadpool being like no we're wiping this
out oh you know we bought it maybe he's
gonna hunt down yeah uh Hugh Jackman's
Logan before he can join the MCU or
maybe before yeah he's like I gotta get
you out of here because you're gonna get
killed that seems interesting so hard to
do because they both regenerate
but there was a comic issue where all of
the Adam adamantium
adamantium was taken out of his body by
uh Magneto yeah and he was just like oh
and he was fighting Deadpool so it was
like if something like that happens yeah
well they killed Wolverine for a little
while they put him in a statue of like
they covered him with liquid adamantium
and he was like Frozen in a statue for
many years in the comics they kept a Jed
for a little while it was kind of nice
we all enjoy it and if we're if we're
taking you know the second video in good
faith from Ryan Reynolds that like the
timeline implications again Eric Voss is
going to go into depth about this and
where this could fall in the timeline in
a separate video on this channel like
could this be like taking place in
between the last you know
um uh whatever some the last X-Men movie
in the timeline and Logan right it's
taking place before the 2029 of Logan
yeah I mean that's what he's kind of
implicating in that video you know that
this will be before but even more than
that right like you can leave all of
that alone yeah this can just be a
different Wolverine yeah multiversal
yeah
I don't think they need to make it more
complicated than that all I know is
Deadpool better interact with Kevin
feige and this movie I love that theory
I want to see them talk to each other at
some point like establish Kevin as the
one above all you know make be like he
is he is the God of this universe uh and
like really establish that I think it'd
be great I just want Wolverine Deadpool
and cable to all be there I do want
cable to come back what the hell are we
all doing one of our super Chatters had
put it on I don't see it anymore I uh
bringing Domino back and I would like
Domino's
I hope so I don't think Daisy beats has
been announced yeah yeah but she is a
lot she was alive at the end of Deadpool
too right
they haven't confirmed that yet if she's
gonna be understood she said she was
down right
now
Christian unpronounceable who had
brought up Bernie Domino back especially
seeing the luck power I did like the
luck power yeah because a lot of time in
the comics especially early comic
Scarlet Witch her thing was like her
chaos was like just altering events uh
which is a very fun thing to see played
out and the concept of like luck uh and
chaos and all that kind of stuff working
it's really cool I would like to see
that thank you to Nina you the MJ 2987
Claudia Vazquez we have reached the
bonus time oh baby
so we will have a bonus segment at the
end of the show where we will go into
more depth answering any Deadpool
questions reading out theories any blade
questions reading out there yeah you
want to get your insane theories out
Now's the Time because you control them
and these are both super chats and
regular chats we'll be trying to grab
those actually tag the new Rockstar's
account oh yeah if you have a question
or a theory and that'll help them grab
it uh and we're gonna get to at least 15
minutes worth of questions which is a
lot but 15 minutes is a lot of time that
is a long time
you can gather a lot of trash in 15
minutes and have them all start chatting
you can play several rounds of a Disney
Emoji Blitz you can play 15 minutes you
could make up an ag1 and drink it and go
to the bathroom in 15 bites
well Tommy that's something you might do
yeah you know something you will do yeah
there's something
mandatory coming down the train oh yeah
coming down
I don't know
oh God there's someone on the tracks
it's time for the mandatory fun
segments so deadly we play the graphics
straight to your head Lee hit it again
I thought you were gonna say in a medley
oh play the graphic again
the segment that makes me feel so
relaxed that we play the Thirsty
thespian graphic on wax hit it for me
I didn't hear it until one time I was
watching the break room and there's
noise with it yeah
I thought it was someone peeing in a
bathroom we don't have we don't have to
hear the noise but the audience does so
hit it again no yes
oh yeah
someone someone get aiming out of that
way it's Wednesday you know what that
means ah it's time for She-Hulk
predictions why don't we take a look at
uh the current scores can we show those
do we have that where am I now 35 wow
the trash is in the league the trash is
in the lead what's gonna happen if the
trash wins because the winner gets the
the fancy dinner of their choice mine's
gonna be chicken fingers cut and
bite-sized pieces so I don't choke
that's not a fancy thing
for me it is for me when you grow up
like I grew up anything with real
protein in it it's not working that's a
rat base my choice my choice for for the
meal is going to be the most dangerous
things I can eat whole grapes uh Hot
Dogs cut into corn yes
already knows in the chat hashtag
Seafood
trust me the lizard lizard will be going
down on some pinks hot dogs if we get
that all right don't you worry please
I'm just gonna have 36 feet of
uh moving on uh this week we've got a
whole new episode and it appears as
though uh Blonsky will be getting our
Emil Blonsky fix in with his uh with his
Wellness tree here's the questions I
have for you guys this has been teased
we know he's coming is this the week
Daredevil finally appears I said
yeah okay I also said yes because
there's only a few with this is this
will be episode seven three more episode
seven eight and nine left they don't
they won't drop them in the last episode
the only rumored that he would be in the
last three and I was like I want it so
bad that I'm just gonna put my money in
tonight's episode to be like a 36 minute
episode I need them to do without
without the Portuguese credits yeah yeah
I said no why dude I said no to
Daredevil why no you think he just shows
up in the finale I think they're teasing
us again oh and I said I really want to
stretch it well what if it's like a
little bit of little credits I
oh yeah we should ask if there's gonna
be a post-credit team as a bonus because
it hasn't been in the last few weeks I
still don't think there is uh I say c c
there will be Daredevil uh now we know
everyone uh Emil blonsky's Meditation
Retreat is going to be featured uh
pretty heavily in this episode how many
super powered Retreat members do we
think we're gonna see in this episode at
the retreat no not outside of it it has
to be on the Emile blonski property and
this includes includes of meal blocks
total superhuman people not the parole
officer that's clearly not a super they
gotta have powers I said seven seven
seven okay odd number I went I went one
more I went eight I lowballed it I'm
going six oh and I went friggin huge I
went 12. I think there's going to be I
think they're gonna like cut over to
like a softball game and there's gonna
be like dudes chatting around ladies
going
you know that's a good idea yeah that
was a good idea thanks guys softball
shot yeah yeah and finally I say it's
volleyball volleyball okay pickleball
opponent emergency injunction okay for
five bonus points okay what sport is
going to be played at the Blonsky
Retreat if any at all okay I I think
they'll go weird wacky I'm gonna say
croquet I was gonna say croquet oh my
God I was genuinely gonna say croquet
them okay I'm saying I'm saying
volleyball you're saying volleyball I'm
gonna stick with uh softball yeah I
genuinely was like it's gonna be Cricket
no it's not gonna be Cricket it's gonna
be crooked all right so that was a rogue
we did we threw some a rogue question so
there's four in there now whoever gets
that one right gets the food immediately
yeah you immediately get a a blizzard
down your lizard
all right now finally the last question
at the end of every episode we get these
beautiful watercolor courtroom uh uh
sketch style sketches of the episode how
many do we think they will have in the
credits this week
I think I went big I said I said 11.
because there's genuinely a lot yeah as
someone that does the break challenge
all right as though that does the
breakdowns I was like it's definitely
more than eight remember these are all
Price is Right rules so it's closest
without going over oh wait a minute
uh I went I went on the lower end I went
six which I'm now second guessing I feel
like I should run higher well I went for
five and I believe that from my shouter
to my spouter
completely wrong
I love what the whole family gets
involved uh yeah I'm the black sheep
we'll get you there someday you're
you're our princess are you kidding me I
can't wait to get a bigger Tiara all
right and then I said uh I said seven so
I am I kind of did the old Price is
Right Edge out of Zach and Brandon but
I'm just below Jessica so if there's
eight nine or ten your boy gets the
points I hate the way that I understand
it it's just like you so you have to low
you should go low you should always go
low I mean you could bet one dollar that
like if someone about one second I think
oh no actually Corey was right on with
the episode length I was a little I was
a little over dashel broke the news
anyway the point is it's still anybody's
game this meal this gourmet meal at a
place on the wall of Champions which
doesn't don't pan over because there's
nothing there um
what if there was just like a crude
drawing of me kissing stick figure me
kissing a girl like all my drawings
uh yeah that's what we got guys it's
anyone's game don't forget to watch
Seahawk tonight and catch up on Andor if
you didn't watch it last night yeah we
got scores like yesterday for Andor I I
truly I truly randomly guessed
everything
I had the most points because I had
Cassie right now right now it's me it
goes Brandon Zach and then me and you
are tied for last is it because the barn
woman
I gave you points for uh using a kiss to
manipulate someone which is what she did
with her boyfriend Tim when she was like
I can I just stay here did anyone do the
droids the the not that Droid no one
said that no one said unfortunately no
no no
and then uh yeah and then what else did
you give oh you got points for using uh
secret code to do Rebels to buy things
and again we're we're doing we're doing
two simultaneous fantasy prediction
leagues here one for She-Hulk that is uh
pretty straightforward we're guessing
specific things for episodes the one for
Andor is 100 subjective based on Tommy's
whims yeah uh it's really a psycho's
playground uh anything goes from uh from
your processor to your raw dresser I
think you were your raw dresser and you
point to your thoughts we'll run a poll
for who who chat wants to pick for their
She-Hulk prediction yes of the four of
us
a couple other polls today it seems like
we asked how excited people are for a
werewolf super excited to 54 and then
interested 38 and then like very low for
the other two so it seems like most
people are pretty hyped on this they're
gonna doing a good job and it's also
nice to be like hey you only have to
watch a one-hour special yep less than
an hour I'm going to the lesson
as playing at Beyond Fest whoa no
werewolf by night it is yeah I have fun
I have two tickets just in case anyone
wants to come with me but I literally
was like I was like it's at 10 45 p.m
when is that that's late that's late
that's werewolves October late night by
late night I'm an old man oh not I was
born
you're the baby
following along knows the Canon of the
break room Brandon was born in 2002. uh
Tommy is uh currently facing
prostitution for a variety of crimes I'm
89 years old
uh we also asked which Deadpool 3 plot
idea you like the most and most of you
seem to like the idea of Deadpool kills
the fox
kills the fox X-Men universe so that
means he'd kill like everyone like our
first Rogue our first like everybody
maybe today's a future past like pulled
everything together and so did Logan in
a way I mean and even you know who else
was in the fox uh superhero Universe the
original Fantastic Four characters too
Jessica Alba and you know did they kill
uh David Hasselhoff as Nick Fury
the highlight of the New Mutants for me
was I took my nephew to go see it during
covid so there was like when the
drive-ins made a huge comeback and I I
went to go get um snacks and my nephew
who's constantly pranking me uh got a
little too complacent and I snuck up to
the window and pounded on it and he
jumped into the back seat of the car
like he's never been more terrified in
his life I like how you like the movie I
don't know anything about the movie but
that was a real highlight for me oh
it was the best part shout out to the
entire back told household um okay so
real quick again tag at uh the new
rockstars account in the chat if you
have any blade or Deadpool 3 predictions
questions anything like that I think we
can commence our bonus 15 minutes yeah
let's get it on Q a here we're gonna
start off I just want to shout out a
couple
um quick super chats here BL s is saying
there's a reason why they called a
garbage can and not a garbage can not
that's right
and all you little trash bags know it
huh uh and it looks like Chad's going
with Jess for there she always go with
jazz is it because of the crown they
love it
they got respect for the beautiful
Beauty before brains they always
says
oh Mikey cheers saying uh Fan cast
female pool I assume that means like a
female Deadpool yeah oh they do like a
gender swap I think like that's you know
people were saying Jody Comer for Sue
storm Jody Comer as like a Deadpool
because if you haven't seen her in
killing Eve she's so good at killing you
she's great in everyone she's her
playing like a psychotic kind of also
she's worked with uh Sean Levy and Ryan
Reynolds
she's in that Universe I mean even just
Jody Comer showing up in Deadpool 3 as
some character yeah feels like it can
actually broadcasting please yeah
Cameron Diaz
Cameron Diaz yeah she's a sassy she can
be very funny she be very witty she's
doing a lot of comedies in the late 90s
early 2000s where she was super funny if
you've ever seen Bad Teacher I think
criminally underrated and kind of ruined
in the from the original draft into what
made it to the screen but she's really
freaking funny that's the one that has
the when he's fighting with the kid
about Michael Jordan versus LeBron James
uh I'm leaning LeBron James but you want
to love LeBron James as female Deadpool
oh my God that would be perfect
explode I don't know how to even process
that yeah um no I want I want your
person yeah yeah she's great
if the Sue storm uh casting comes out
and it's not her it's been rumored that
she's in that but we've got some
confirmation that she's not yet cast in
that role uh it would be awesome to get
her some somewhere in the MCU do you see
John krasinski's retweets that were like
this is our film yeah he's trying to get
in on it yeah
he might be the most
and that's some good news we're also
we're all missing the you know the
female Deadpool is Blake Lively that's
right get out of here
leave this right there for you did their
marriage survive that she's too busy
doing the simple favor and it's an
amazing movie but I want her did that
movie come out five minutes okay
it comes on movie John yeah
and that's bite-sized reviews from
zachies because he you can see he's
saying Hell yeah
uh kaijo Rin saying you know what
there's something we've been talking
about I know this shows up a lot in the
chat we want to get an all-female break
room episode we hear you kaijo Rand we
know that our our gender uh parody not
so good it's something we're working on
behind the scenes to uh get uh get some
more ladies on the on the it's Philip
Molina who keeps blocking it yeah
there's a couple problematics
we have six female hosts hanging out
right there in a containment unit
of uh
no he's a good guy I want to see the
squirrel I mean more than I want to see
some stupid girl play Deadpool I want to
see a squirrel and other animals did you
talk about on the break room yeah yeah
can we have puppets all right why why is
this circle back to that point uh
Teenage jokes thanks God damn Zach as
I'm just talking about gender parodies
like I don't see some stupid girls
fight fight physically fight the softy
Brothers don't fight each other are they
breaking up no we can't please turn a
deal because that may become hard
Brothers
not to be confused of the hearty brother
boys who have won a lot of Tag Team
Championships softy Brothers Hardy Boy
uh teeny gems in the chat team bring
Domino background boycott in the movie
Just on the open house oh yeah TD
usually money to speak yeah Domino is
great uh and we yeah as we said we loved
her and we want to see more of her um
Claudine Vasquez saying rom-com Style
movie between Deadpool and Wolverine
yeah kind of like a uh you know male
bonding kind of that's the big thing
they did with the second one or the
first one because it came out on
Valentine's Day they were trying to like
counter programs
the no the super chats really yeah we
got uh MJ 2997 Deadpool by night I like
that wow uh we got some Tanya again
Tanya Tyler Natasha L Nina you think you
all Ben Enoch uh oh man enough down
there in the in the hurricane uh take
care of yourself everybody in uh Florida
Gulf Coast all those places I hope
you're doing well we're sending well
wishes we got a lot of folks in New York
if you're using your generator to watch
this don't don't waste your generating
power on yes waste your generator power
plug-in in your phone and type it in a
super chat a lot of us that do rock
stars grew up in Florida we know what
it's like we we're we're pulling for you
guys and I grew up in Florida I grew up
on the west coast and we don't really
get oh we got earthquakes me
didn't that team lose
oh come on
um Tommy literally just I saw his soul
leave his body for a second uh and all
that was left behind was raised okay I'm
sorry
okay we got some other uh cool super
chats and chats in general uh Brandon
you want to read out a couple of those
others I can't see who said it but so
yesterday you guys were talking about
Deadpool oh we did really
Eldritch uh Ein I don't know how to
pronounce your name Eldritch but that's
an awesome name uh okay and right there
at the beginning of the Super Chat you
don't have to say too late well I
attempted it probably butchered it
um uh I suspect uh Adam project and free
guy are extended Multiverse via Deadpool
yes Reynolds a force of nature I hope
they they have to make some sort of free
guy did such a good job and they made so
much money that they will I hope they
make some connection even if it's just
him listening to every Mariah Carey song
is I'm is that Irish
accent fragrance was was poor was asking
like when do you think we'll see blade
in the MCU kind of like saying do you
think we would see blade before okay so
I like talking about this right like do
we see another saw blade
yes and so far right all the characters
that have been arriving in post-credit
scenes are not confirmed to be in future
properties right uh Harry Styles is uh
Eros right we don't know what it is who
knows Hercules uh um Charlize Theron's
uh character from Multiverse of Madness
we don't know Cleo we don't know when
any of these are gonna show up Blade's
kind of the only post-credit character
we know is getting a film or a show
right and so like do we see mahershala
as blade sometime before this film comes
I think blade is you know he's going
around the East Coast uh he stops in New
Jersey he's getting some coffee at a
little coffee shop and a little
neighborhood and this woman walks in
that seems a little odd and he
recognizes her because she's Agatha
Harkness the evil witch but she's not
acting like I got the Harkness what is
she doing blade kills everyone in the
coffee shop steals ago the hardness no
that's what he got that's how the show
we haven't been talking about so as of
right now House of Harkness is scheduled
to come out after play
right in Phase five uh I can't see the
graphic but yes it is yes right almost
isn't a coven of chaos now
okay okay
so but I mean if blade could get delayed
maybe it comes out after uh Covenant of
chaos and maybe then but maybe
mahershala makes an appearance there I
like that
um one thing we've been speculated
speculating on for a while do we see a
midnight Suns oh we have the video game
coming out looks pretty fun Bucky Barnes
I saw your chat thank you for the nine
dollars to go buy a beer unfortunately
I have too many ag1s in my stomach right
now and the beer would just be absorbed
quite powerful yeah the greens would
shoot it out GSU Eagle 117 uh suggesting
for the extra 15 minutes that everyone
in the office should challenge each
other to a classic fight uh using
multiple parts of their body
unfortunately the HR department will not
allow us yeah and by the way that is my
style guys you know I trained with the
grapes least ago uh Stevens ago said no
I'm sorry Jason Siegel
I said the lead was uh slightly it was
former Philly's pitcher Cliff Lee uh
same just because uh so by the chance of
being a hater who are these haters in
the chair yeah haters in the chat I got
one thing to tell you get ready to have
mouth hands and blood all over you okay
no reward s I'm coming at you with all
three father son and holy spirit thank
you Sean Davis for the Super Chat Jason
morante asking do you think Elsa
Bloodstone is a heartbringer of the
death of Doctor Strange or midnight Sons
well in a couple I want to talk about in
relation particularly to Blade right
Elsa Bloodstone shows up in Midnight
Sun's uh comics and stories every once
in a while so she could come back right
that talented actress from the never
series and she's done a lot of stuff if
we see her I guess we have to make sure
she survives werewolf by night but uh if
she shows up with more properties and
then the most recent Shield episode
right had a tiny Easter egg about was it
Madame blood or whatever that uh Mr
Immortal he references one of his
previous wives right is his character am
I getting it right Madame blood who's
like blood Cromwell or baroness Cromwell
yes so it could be
I I suggest I think it's just King
Henry's the third wife
oh no there's Mr Immortal musical it's
um okay why couldn't he be he loves
wives could he have been King Henry oh
he could I think he was we can get into
this hey Kate the tutors the tutus but
it could be because people were
suspecting it could be her uh the
baroness and I was like yeah now we're
getting into spooky stuff we easily
could I would like to lean if we had to
choose one to lean I would the the chat
went away with the person's name uh Elsa
Bloodstone yeah I'd rather it be else
yeah but I just like the idea like we
just met an immortal character vampires
traditionally are Immortal right like
maybe he would have crossed paths with
another Immortal maybe a vampire have
been married or before New Jersey they
stopped by a car Jane Seymour's sister
thank you you guys Jane Seymour has an
assistant yeah and that's baroness
Cromwell oh Jane Seymour not the actress
from uh
where the Hulk are all these
super-powered individuals coming from
yeah talking about this is like an
interesting idea in She-Hulk it's like
suddenly there's all these people with
powers mostly on the west coast as far
as we know uh but why you know people
don't seem super phased by it they're
they seem to be cool with it now this
show is interesting because it is kind
of a comedy and we haven't really viewed
the MCU through the lens of a comedy
before super common you know you can
argue that yeah man's a little more
comedic the ragnarok's like a little
more comedic but this is like mostly
comedy but it has the MCU just kind of
like gotten used to so much weird stuff
going on I mean we've already we already
talked about this in the office all the
time and on big question and stuff where
it's like these are citizens who have
lived through half the population
getting wiped out and then coming back
and also there's Tiamat and also oh
giant space robots have shown about this
guy yeah there's been aliens we kind of
just came out of nowhere yeah so it's
like at this point they're like oh I
don't care if there's a guy walking
Street who's a bull
s yeah 100 doesn't even bother him
anymore I mean I don't care if there's a
green bull hanging out a convertage
that's no problem we can just have that
be no big deal everyone knows wait wait
wait you think that's weirder than just
the existence of camera tires
what a stranger a bull that's a man or a
man that's a bull well would you rather
man
well also right like this is all it's
kind of a metaphor for us the viewer
right we all started with Iron Man one
much like the MCU did right where it's
like nobody with superpowers it's a guy
he built something from a box of scraps
right it's all science and believability
but like over time as we've met you know
uh masters of the mystical Arts as we've
met you know aliens we've met like uh
Eternal creatures and stuff like that we
have become like more open-minded to man
bulls and uh I certainly have evolved a
lot on my staunch anti-manville stance
in my college years when I marched again
I love it you love a Ponyboy you always
I love a bony horse I love a pony boy
yeah booty beads in the chat
um but it's also a case of like the
movies aren't necessarily there to catch
us up on everything that yeah at ground
level that's more for the shows and even
think about like yeah if Mambo's not out
there like trying to destroy the world
or take over foreign government why
would his storyline ever rise to the
point where the Avengers need to care
about him right I mean we all you all
got that guy in your downtown district
there's a he's a little wacky and he's
hanging around and he wears crazy things
he does crazy things to you you see him
every day you're like oh that's just the
crazy guy in downtown who wears 20
bathrooms there's a guy in Burbank uh
not too far from our office yeah uh no
our office is not somewhere on the Dark
Side of the Moon first there's a guy
there's a guy for years I've seen this
man all the time in a full this is
before even the Mandalorian series
started in the full Boba Fett on an
electric uh skateboard going like 30
miles an hour uh he rides around L.A is
he single doing that all the time
um and it's like that guy could be at
some kind of power and he loves to go to
Subway and he tells the cashier all the
time I could take this home hot or I
could take this home cold it doesn't
matter to me and by the way
hold it on him for a second by the way
if you don't think you have a crazy
person in your town that means you are
the craziest
hey if I'm in your yard that means
you're going crazy
out to dinner let him finish what he was
gonna say Morris uh was saying is it
possible it's set in the 838 Universe I
I assume talking about Deadpool Deadpool
3. Eric thinks that right isn't that
Eric that would be an interesting like
buff like because I assume the a38 we
saw and I don't know about Multiverse
hopping was it the same year when they
go to the a3a is that what there's no
time travel when you're Crossing yeah
are you cross is it a straight like
one-to-one time transfer when you hop
University are you talking about the end
of Deadpool 2 well no no I'm talking
sorry I'm talking about Multiverse of
Madness when he goes to the a3a and it's
like oh it seems much more futuristic
now is that because Reed Richards back
in the 60s started doing stuff and like
totally changed the trajectory of
society I don't know but it did seem
like they were in a future version of
the world I but that's what I don't know
about how it works but you bring up a
good point of at the end of Deadpool
when like he's jumping around he goes to
see Ryan Reynolds before he uses Cable's
Powers right to travel through time and
go see Ryan Reynolds yeah yeah I mean
it'll be very hard to make that
post-credit scene in Blade too in uh
Deadpool 2 Canon right yeah yeah where
he's literally going in and he saves his
wife yeah I was like leave everything
leave everything as is I also want I
want someone to be like acknowledge when
Deadpool's talking to the screen like do
they see Deadpool turn and like talk to
something or does it do they not even
see it happen is it like Saved by the
Bell where he's doing it outside of time
well that's interesting point and one
other character that already is in the
MCU that does that She-Hulk could
She-Hulk show up in Deadpool 3 uh and
they both try to break the fourth wall
at the same time
like he gets like uh arrested and she's
the lawyer and she's like what the hell
is going on I mean it goes to like one
of the things I like most about Rick and
Morty which you gotta have a really high
IQ to appreciate Rick and Morty
which you do uh the idea that Rick is
aware that he's in a show and the whole
reason he goes on these crazy Avengers
is because like if they don't keep
making the show he dies which is true in
a weird way this idea that a character
you've created is aware of his own
mortality and that like if there's not
an audience watching me I don't exist so
that's why he has to make the show so
fun and entertaining and have like Wubba
lubba dub dub and all that [ __ ] like
that's so fascinating to me so the idea
that Deadpool knows we're watching and
has to make good movies or else they
won't keep making Deadpool movies all
right it's fascinating and like I would
love it if Deadpool acknowledges like
they bought my studio out and like I'm
gonna get canceled and like Kevin feige
won't let me see say [ __ ] his
universe and I need to figure this out
like what am I going to do like is this
is a struggle for his own life I believe
elf had a similar self-awareness the
puppet elf puppet if you ever read about
what it was like making ALF look that up
because it was hell on Earth for
everyone check it off on your bingo card
yeah
quick one last Super Chat I want to
shout out uh oh well a couple of others
BL saying uh have we predicted Deadpool
3 based on Deadpool kills Marvel
Universe except it's Deadpool kills the
fox Universe yeah we gotta talked about
that a little bit BL but we like that
idea that's certainly in the running I
mean JH saying blade will be in wakanda
Hulk is a mutant
um play will be in wakanda uh
interesting
um in the comics they're not really
connected
um I would love it if like Neymar wins
at the very end he's taking over and
then just this Giant Knife right it cuts
his wet Footprints of blood leading to
the throne yes the dumb flatbreads I
would also like to bring up when you
brought out Alf earlier I was born in
2002 and I have no idea what that is
yeah elf was a puppet that had his own
sitcom and that is on Late Night show
and then weirdly mostly POG and sticker
things for a while wasn't he like an
anteater
I think also loved lasagna or Mike no
that's Garfield okay
lasagna yes I only know from this
because of Family Guy he literally ate
cats and we were okay with it okay so
then we cheered him on as he did it we
never we fed him those cats have uh oh
uh Greener saying in the chat have
Deadpool 3 start with being pruned by
the TVA
get very complicated but I love it um
Rockstar's chat is our is uh is coming
for us they said keep talking about
Alfia Boomers whoa
that's that's producer John that's
producer producer John's the oldest one
out of all of us John was born in
1972 I believe that's right uh he's
turning 50 this year yeah all right well
I think we've over delivered on our
bonus 15 minutes I think it's closer to
bonus 23 minutes at this point thank you
everybody that stuck with us if you if
you're still watching hit like on this
video hit that thumbs up yeah then if
you do it right now you'll get to see
that number tick up as a bunch of your
friends who are also watching yes when
you feel powerful and then subscribe too
we're sick of it okay stop playing your
games subscribe to the channel okay no
hiding from me one game one game you can
keep playing Emoji Blitz don't forget to
watch it's great on the toilet y'all
coming out tonight and we'll be talking
about the episode tomorrow so we'll see
you tonight about the episode tomorrow
Jessica will have a breakdown up on
Friday keep it good I think I have a
breakdown for barbarian coming out oh
yeah that's right also tomorrow yeah
yeah and I'll be breaking down in my
shower this evening uh and I'm gonna
I'll be breaking down the new to be
films uh Johnny Depp trial yeah
thank you and if you guys don't give us
a thousand in super chats by Friday I'll
bring down the monsters that's a threat
supposedly it's good yeah it's supposed
to be good I like Rob Zombie uh all
right everybody
says it's great
what does water magazine say they say
was it Tim Allen
I'm from 2002. I don't know who Jimmy
all right nice Buzz Lightyear it's the
Santa Claus thank you all for watching
the Tool Man